so as we get into the Age of Apocalypse
what we do here is we start with an
event called the legion quests now while
a lot of things happen in this
miniseries for the most part the main
focus of the story is legion the son of
Charles Xavier traveling into the past
to kill Erik Lehnsherr now the reason
for this as Allegiant explains is due to
the fact that if Erik Lehnsherr never
became Magneto then Xavier stream of a
peaceful coexistence between humans and
mutants would most likely succeed the
reason being because one magneto
wouldn't have instilled in humanity I
guess the fear or the inherent fear of
mutants and to Xavier wouldn't have to
focus on dealing with Magneto and humans
instead he could just focus on dealing
with humans however what we find is that
when Legion jumps into the past he's
followed by the x-men and Bishop who
attempt to try to stop Legion from
making changes to the timeline but as we
know they're ultimately unsuccessful
when Xavier jumps in the way of the
killing blow to save Magneto resulting
in the death of Charles Xavier now in
addition to this at the same time that
all this is happening apocalypse is
basically watching this event unfold and
so when Charles Xavier dies he basically
chooses this moment as the perfect
opportunity to begin his conquest of
North America and the world now from
here we jump to some unspecified time
with magneto having established the
x-men now the reason why I say
unspecified is that we don't have the
exact date and due to the death of
Charles Xavier we don't know if the
x-men are founded earlier or later than
they were normally founded and the
normal timeline but the main purpose of
this story is to really be more of a
prelude to the Age of Apocalypse in the
sense that it establishes not just
magneto as the founder and leader of the
x-men residing in wonder core but it
also establishes who the members of the
x-men are the current roster as it's
composed of the x-men in this story
consists of Iceman Bobby Drake storm
Scarlet Witch Jean Grey and Colossus
alongside the newly recruited Wolverine
who's actually referred to as a Weapon X
in the Age of Apocalypse as well as
rogue now rogues introduction to the
x-men actually comes in the sense that
as far as we can tell rogue was brought
before magneto by mystique at Magneto's
requests now we don't know if rogue had
already been around mystique worth
mystique basically had to
can find her and then bring her to
magneto when in truth it probably
doesn't really matter that much here
what does matter is that apocalypse has
basically already started his conquest
of the world by launching an attack
against Cape Citadel which houses
multiple nuclear warheads now where
apocalypse initially makes his
appearance here in the assault against
Cape Citadel what we also find is that
among his henchmen is Sabretooth but due
to the arrival of the x-men and their
victory or I guess temporary victory
over apocalypse and their capture of
Sabretooth apocalypse basically retreats
and Sabretooth is left behind now at
this point we pick up with x-men alpha
and what this does is it officially
launches the Age of Apocalypse event in
the sense that we basically jump forward
in time to see that apocalypse has
already taken over North America in
addition to this we're met with the
arrival of Bishop but what we also get
is this sort of tour of what the world
looks like now that apocalypse is
effectively taken over North America
what we find here is that we pick up
with Bishop as he simply traveling
through Seattle when he's basically set
upon by some young girl now what's
revealed to us here is that this young
girl is actually human and that she's
being pursued by a group called the
infinite now the infinite or a group
that are tasked by apocalypse stationed
in various cities around North America
and they're assigned to eliminate humans
wherever they're found as well as take
mutants alive for examination and
processing the result is that when
Bishop uses powers to repel the
infinites he draws their attention to
the fact that he's a mutant but he also
gains the attention of the x-men who've
actually just arrived now by this time
the X should have actually boasted their
ranks with Nightcrawler with blink who
is a mutant that can create portals as
well as Sabretooth who they basically
indoctrinated to their cause and so
after the infinites are defeated Bishop
immediately sets on Magneto
due to the fact that as far as Bishop
recalls before the timeline changed
magneto made no effort to stop Legion
when Legion killed Xavier so the result
is that magneto basically uses his
powers to slow the flow of blood to
bishops brain and to knock him out so
they can take Bishop back to their base
for questioning now from here we switch
to dark beast and the pens now with the
introduction of dark beast we get this
understanding of what all is taking
place regarding how things work under
Apocalypse what
learn is that unlike the normal timeline
of Hank McCoy this version of beast is
very very dark and he actually serves a
purpose of genetically manipulating and
experimenting on mutants for the purpose
of boosting their powers or boosting the
powers of weaker mutants and that all
mutants who are deemed too weak to
basically hold their own or to be to be
held among the normal ranks of
apocalypse are held captive in a place
called the pens until their powers can
be boosted what we also learn is that
the Pens themselves fall under the
direct jurisdiction of mr. sinister and
that havoc and Cyclops are actually kind
of surrogate sons that relied to reside
directly under him now the actions of
dark beasts and manipulating the genes
of various mutants should have actually
ended some time ago since the apocalypse
is basically struck a deal with the
human High Council which is a council
composed of what's left of humanity in
the world and that the as far as the
agreement goes as long as apocalypse
stops his experimentation on humans and
mutants the human High Council will
basically stay hands off from
apocalypses regime but it's actually
revealed to us when sinister meets with
apocalypse that apocalypse is
cooperation with the human High Council
is actually a ruse and that what he
intends to do is to basically take
advantage of the willingness to
cooperate in order to launch an attack
against the world as a whole and take
everything over now at this point we
jump to a place called heaven which is
actually kind of this a neutral zone for
humans and mutants and it's actually ran
by Warren Worthington who in the Age of
Apocalypse never became archangel and he
never joined the x-men what we're also
told is that in terms of heaven at the
moment that gambit actually arrives here
and the reason why gambit arrives is
because his intention is to reach out to
magneto by going through angel and the
reason for this is because angel due to
heaven being a neutral zone has dealings
with magneto with the human High Council
and with Apocalypse himself now while
angel is actually a little reluctant to
assist gambit and helping him get to a
magneto in order for heaven to basically
maintain its neutrality he also really
chooses to help gambit as long as gambit
agrees never to enter Heaven again and
so at this point we basically switch
back to the x-men and we pick up with
magneto in a robe and this is actually
really cool here what we learn is that
they've actually produced a child
named after Charles Xavier and the
reason they were able to do this is
because magneto was basically able to
manipulate his power to allow him or
allow rogue to physically touch him
without her actually harming him now I
would go as far as to say that he's
basically shielded his entire body with
some sort of electromagnetic field of
some kind with the exception of the fact
that when the two of them actually had
intercourse that they were able to
produce a child as a result of his
actions but again what we find is that
due to Apocalypse having had almost all
the telepaths and almost all the time
traveling mutants killed off the only
way for magneto to basically verify the
claims of Bishop and that this world is
not the way it's supposed to be is to
actually have rogue touch Bishop and so
what happens is that when rogue touches
Bishop there's this kind of psychic
backlash in the sense that while rogue
gains bishops memories so does everybody
else
and so everybody sees the way the world
is supposed to be not everyone in the
sense of everybody in the world but
everybody in the immediate vicinity so
magneto gambit rogue and so on they see
how the world's actually supposed to be
here and so what happens is they realize
that in the correct reality before the
Age of Apocalypse took place that
Charles Xavier would go on to launch a
campaign for a peaceful coexistence
between humans and mutants they find out
that magneto is actually supposed to be
a villain and so on and so forth and so
with magneto basically learning how
things are supposed to be learning of
this reality is not the way it's
supposed to be what he does is he an act
a plan and so what we'll find out in the
next video is what this plan is we'll
find that he actually brings together a
multitude of mutants he sends Generation
X to Seattle to to capture I guess to
bring back some various mutants from the
pens we see that gambit and his team
will be sent into space we find out all
kinds of things are going to be going on
and that all this is going to go towards
the goal of defeating apocalypse when
that being said we're going to go ahead
and bring this video to an end I hope
you guys enjoyed it if you did let me
know and I will catch you guys later
peace